in addition to choosing major break
points we're layout changes
significantly it's also helpful to add
minor break points to make some small
changes for example between major break
points it may be helpful to adjust
margins and padding's on an element or
to increase the font size to make things
a little bit easier to read and feel
more natural in the layout in this case
let's boost the font when the viewport
width is between 400 and 550 pixels
where our break point kicks in I'll also
separate the low and high temperature so
that they're not on the same line and
make the weather icons bigger as well
let's switch to the source and all add a
media query that's applied when the
viewport is between 450 and 550 pixels
it ups the base font changes the low and
high temperature to be inline-block and
increases the icon size I'll save the
file and then take a look in the browser
sure enough my icons are now bigger my
fonts are now bigger and everything
looks like I expect it to in this
before-and-after you can see how things
have really changed the icons are much
bigger the font sizes have also changed
and the minimum and maximum temperatures
are now shown in a slightly different
way for larger viewports I want to limit
the maximum width of the forecast panel
so that it doesn't consume the entire
viewport as it gets wider I already have
a link style sheet with min width query
of 700 pixels so in there I just need to
set some margins and padding let's take
a look I'll set the width to 700 pixels
and set margin left and margin right to
auto I'll come back to Chrome hit
refresh and now we've got what I want
there you have it you can use minor
breakpoints to adjust the little things
and really make things sign